yeah welcome to this five-minute damn
undone up okay before it's always a
challenge against the other high rated
let's play playing on Molly for so I
willow pass and let's see what line yeah
I've got the the classical main line of
the room to play down the side seven
just toying a bit I don't want to make a
draw okay night d2l that's the right
move okay so run its ages that I had
looked at the Sun this opening
I think it's a form but I really forgot
there's a 4 and and other moves a for
age six and now Bishop to see two I
think I had looked at this for four
black like half a lifetime ago yeah but
this is actually one of the the old main
lines that has been discussed in them um
like a spawn off against cup of matches
Knight to d7 and turn night h 2 f 5m was
one line that they discussed more than
once and generally a cup of had quite
good positions but he lost he lost lots
of games and this line may be okay three
I don't know pretty taking on rook III
may be okay three yeah he lost lots of
games simply because um white also all
the time has got them some attack I mean
look at just look at this kind of
position it's prob maybe black is better
it's possible but I've got both bishops
on on the king we should be 1 C 1 they
are attacking pieces from the back rank
night only for rukon g3 night comes to
g4 and yeah this position they had this
kind of position they had all the time
with Karpov having a good position but
he simply lost so many games out of a
lot of good positions that it was it was
terrible okay I play Knight g4 now and
take on age 6 next move and it's a
disaster i think how does he defend
now it takes h6 the rukon g3 is not
exactly a bad okay so i take on age 60
king 2 h8 and then what hmm hmm i don't
really is this still playable for black
it's hard to believe
Knight takes h6 checking h8 I don't see
move after that amazingly
I don't see move I can go Queen h5 yeah
luckily one check King age too I can
simply take the night there's no maid
there really is no mail Queen f5 maybe I
cannot take on de force well you can
take the rook with check which is super
annoying okay I need to do this year
anyway otherwise I'm toast while Queen D
for was the great defensive move for a
name
yeah i mean probably this is just not
working but what else rookie one king
edge 2 and then takes on age 6 yeah
maybe just bishop jakes oh yeah okay
this is cannot this is you must do that
round a threatening night f7 checking g8
Bishop h7 checkmate if he takes Bishop
takes threatening discoveries Bishop g7
Bishop evade with mate mmm yeah I can
just take on age 6 of course I simply
didn't take that into account at first
but it is his winning maybe it was
winning and he doesn't have a counter
attack right the serious one okay
yeah it is much it is much Bishop takes
f8 Bishop g7
yeah don't get me wrong I'm not saying I
play like power off or something but
this is the kind of way that cap off
sometimes lost these games just just out
of completely great positions Kasparov
going to the tech and made it him these
are really great games if you happen if
you have some time on your hands look at
those those games in the Rue Lopez
between those two all-time greats just
great chess great fighting chance yeah
probably this is really gone I don't see
how I how I defense yeah yep at least I
have no choice okay okay I can I can
take him I can take and no Queen edge
five right yeah and queen age 6 yeah
this was really nice but I have no idea
it maybe this is some even some some
theoretical line I mean I'm pretty sure
that this has been played before at some
point it was just a coincidence of
course I didn't I didn't plan anything
yeah I the computer yeah yeah yeah this
is typical this is so typical I like
this at the end and went for this and if
you take a bit of time white can just
take weight in this position I can take
here rook takes and then Nigel why this
is much much easier of course the black
black doesn't have a moose simply
because it's very easy now this this
defense is not working at all because
now it's it's it's similar to the game
but there's nothing hanging only one I
just
have the same position with an extra
Brook and there's also in addition and I
didn't know this is not on but this is
necessary but just much simpler in the
game let's check out the game he played
this move and in fact the computer says
rookie one Queenie one Queenie 60 fans
ok quindi phone yeah yeah Quinn h5 is
really winning plus 5 but it's much it's
more difficult but of course in
comparison you need to sacrifice the
rook yeah this was really a nice game
yeah and make sure if you have the time
to look at those Kasparov cup of games
that we really really great really great
games yeah thanks for watching